CHESTER LUI: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to Cloud On Air, live
webinars from Google Cloud.
We are hosting
webinars every Tuesday.
And my name is
Chester Lui, and I'll
be talking about protecting
your workforce with Chrome
Enterprise.
You could ask questions
anytime on this platform,
and we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
So this presentation
is really broken down
into three sections.
In the first section, we will
discuss some industry insights
and trends by
cybersecurity and show both
how businesses are impacted.
In the second session, we'll
talk about the security
benefits of Chrome OS, bundled
with enterprise features
unlocked by the Chrome
Enterprise license that can
help your company stay safe.
In the third and final section,
we'll take a look at Google
and how it keeps
its own business
secure from malicious threats.
And with that,
let's get started.
With the growing media reports
of state-sponsored espionage,
financial crime, and
tampering with elections
and other malicious
behaviors, cybercrime
has moved to the forefront
of the current news cycle.
This has not only
become a concern
for individuals but for
businesses of all shapes
and sizes as well.
We face new
challenges, and we have
to keep our businesses secure.
Headlines like these not only
show well-publicized hacks
that have resulted in
significant losses,
they reiterate the
need for businesses
to revisit their
cybersecurity strategy.
IT administrators have
more complexity to manage,
as business demands evolve.
They have to defend
against external attacks
and internal vulnerabilities,
while keeping
the business moving.
With the purveyance of
increasing affordability
of cloud computing, mobile
devices and connectivity,
technology and the
work environment
is vastly different
from what it used to be.
On average-- let's take a look--
an employee typically
has three devices
to do their job, many of which
are not tethered to the desk
and can be used
outside of the office.
The average employee also
has about 22 cloud apps
that are installed,
many of which
have not been approved
by IT administrators.
As a result, security concerns
are greater than ever,
as there are more and more
points of attacks and leakage.
98% of Fortune
500 companies were
affected by malware in 2017.
And as a result of
that, 69% of those
were affected by phishing.
So workers are also
highly targeted
for phishing and
malware attacks.
Google has conducted
research and has
shown that enterprise users
are 6.2 times more likely to be
targeted for phishing
attacks, and 4.3 times more
likely to receive malware
than typical end users.
Given the sheer rate of
enterprises and its employees
as targeted by phishing
and malware threats,
it's important to implement
a strategy that deters
falling prey to these attacks.
Not only are cyber attacks
affecting proprietary company
data, but it's also becoming
a large financial burden.
Current estimates show that the
global cost of data breaches
will reach $2.1 trillion
by the end of 2019,
according to the
Cybersecurity Ventures 2017
cybercrime report.
Hackers are not only
looking to cash in on data,
they're collecting
account passwords.
They're finding new ways
to hold data hostage.
In attacks like ransomware,
data on end-user machines
are encrypted by
a malicious party,
only to be decrypted
with a payment.
Ransomware attacks have
increased 15 times since 2015.
Along with this,
employees continue
to be vulnerable to attacks,
which are increasing
and becoming more complex.
According to the Willis
Towers Watson Cyber Risk
Survey in 2017,
90% of all reported
breaches were caused
by employee negligence.
With the increasing number
of sophisticated back actors,
along with the growing numbers
of vulnerable employees,
these numbers could
continue to be on the rise.
So with the shift targeting
increasing in complexity
amongst the cybersecurity
environment,
IT has to find solutions
and preventative measures
to handle the risks associated
with enterprise threats.
A solution to consider for
this changing cybersecurity
landscape is Chrome Enterprise.
Chrome Enterprise
provides solutions
fit for the workplace
of the future.
We provide a secure,
consistent user experience
across a range of devices
that can be used anywhere
with Chrome OS and granular
controls and enterprise
features with the Chrome
Enterprise license.
When it comes to security,
Chrome Enterprise,
follows three pillars
proactive protections,
evolving defenses,
and granular policies.
These three buckets
come together
to tell a really
compelling story
about how Chrome Enterprise
approaches security
in an entirely different way.
Chrome OS follows a
multi-layered interlocking
approach to proactively
protecting data on the device.
From the hardware to the
firmware to the operating
system to the applications
and ultimately,
the browser level, all
layers of the Chromebook
are working together to provide
a secure computing experience.
So, like I highlighted earlier,
starting at the hardware level,
every Chromebook comes with
a Google-designed hardware
security module that
is tamper resistant
and encrypts all the
data on the device.
At the firmware
level, verify boot
ensures that the operating
system has not been tampered
with by an untrusted source.
Chromebooks are
unique because we
have two versions of Chrome
OS on the device at all times.
So if one version is detected
to have been tampered with,
the Chromebook will
attempt to boot
the other version of the
operating system on the device.
Now let's take a look at
the operating system level.
OS updates and patches
happen in the background
thus ensuring no downtime while
your employees are getting up
to date.
Since there are two
versions of the operating
system on a
Chromebook, the version
that is not being
used by the end user
will be updated
in the background
to prevent interruption,
only to be booted up
upon the next machine start.
No more employees pressing
ignore on update prompts.
Chrome OS also stores
most user data securely
encrypted in the cloud, rather
than locally on the device.
This removes the need to protect
it on the local device thus
removing the threat.
Lastly, at the
application level,
Google Play Protect ensures that
the applications distributed
in Google Play
are not malicious.
We'll talk more
about this in a bit.
So if you look at the
overall value proposition,
all of these benefits come
stock on Chrome OS devices
to ensure a highly secure
computing experience.
Chrome OS comes with Chrome
browser and all of its security
benefits, which come on all
devices with Chrome browser,
no matter the operating system.
In 2017, we had two
security engineering firms
develop two white papers to
examine the relative security
strengths of the three most
popular enterprise browsers,
Chrome browser, Microsoft
Edge, and Microsoft Internet
Explorer.
The research of these
firms have found
that Chrome browser
was able to detect
more phishing sites than
Edge, due to our Safe Browsing
technology--
actually, 83% to 76%.
The research also determined
that Chrome browser
was the quickest of
the three browsers
to patch major security bugs.
Next, I want to talk about
our solution against phishing
attacks.
Chromebooks, in conjunction
with security keys and Safe
Browsing, make G
Suite users secure
against these types of attacks.
First, security keys-- security
keys are supported by G Suite
and provide a second
requirement for authenticating
into your account.
The security key is
a piece of hardware
that can be plugged
directly into, for example,
the USB report on
your device and ensure
that even if your password is
obtained by a malicious party,
they would still need the
security key to login.
Secondly, let's talk
about Safe Browsing.
Safe Browsing warns users
of malicious threats
before they actually happen.
So if a site is detected to be
a phishing site, for example,
the end user will be prompted
to steer clear and turn away.
Finally, and as discussed in
previous slides, Chromebooks
offer background updates.
This ensures end
users are always
up-to-date with the patches and
the most recent vulnerability
patches onboard their
devices and the browser.
Next, let's discuss
Chrome Enterprise license.
The Chrome Enterprise
license unlocks
a collection of
enterprise features
and granular management that
help IT administrators manage
a large fleet of devices
with over 200-plus policies.
All of this plugs into
a legacy infrastructure
and allows administrators
to deploy applications
to their end users.
With userbase policies,
IT administrators
can ensure that
employees are compliant,
regardless of which Chrome
device they are using.
With device-based
policies, IT administrators
can ensure devices adhere
to strict protocols,
regardless of which
user is accessing them.
With Chrome
Enterprise licensing,
IT administrators can
also manage applications
and extensions and distribute
them in a curated list,
based on an end-user group.
And lastly, with fleet
management commands,
IT administrators can
easily provision, monitor,
and lock down devices at
the touch of a button.
The Google Admin console is a
cloud-based device management
portal.
This capability to manage
Chrome browser and OS
started over six years ago.
And we're even more
excited to announce
that we are partnering with
third-party enterprise mobility
management providers
to give you an even
more flexible and broader,
easier access to security
features.
We just announced a partnership
with VMware AirWatch
last year, making them
the first third-party EMM
solution to manage Chromebooks.
We also just announced
new partnerships
with Cisco Meraki, Citrix
Xen Mobile, and IBM Mass 360,
and there are many more to come.
We also have integrated Chrome
OS with Active Directory
to allow customers to enjoy
the benefits of Chrome
within their AD infrastructure.
For those of you
who are unaware,
select Chrome OS devices
support the Google Play Store,
bringing the most popular mobile
app ecosystem to Chromebooks.
With Managed Google
Play, IT administrators
can curate application
lists for employees
and even have different
lists for different groups.
One of the major
benefits of using
Google Play as an application
distribution mechanism
is the malware detection that
happens on the server side.
Google Play has a feature
called Google Play Protect.
This offering scans over
50 billion apps every day
to ensure malware
is not detected.
As a result of this,
over 2 billion devices
are protected by
Google Play Protect
by using applications
deemed to be safe.
Now to our final section.
Let's take a look at how Google
thinks about application access
control and keeps itself secure.
When it comes to
protecting its data,
Google is considered three
areas to ensure properly
security measures that
are put into place.
The first bucket are users.
We need to ensure that
the right users have
the right level of access
to get their jobs done.
The second bucket
is applications.
Applications provide
access to data
that potentially not all
employees can have access to.
And the third bucket is devices.
Google's considers
this deeply when
determining when an
employee can have access.
What types of
devices are employees
accessing from, and
also is the device
a corporate-issued device?
Google ultimately
needs a solution
for detecting this
type of scenario.
So when you combine
these three things,
you leverage a methodology
called Beyond Core, which
is essentially tiered access.
In a tiered access
model, policies
are set at a corporate level.
So internal services are
classified by trusted tier.
User credentials,
for example, are
verified when resources requests
are made from specific devices.
Given this information, access
to data and applications
are granted if the risk profile
of the end user and device
matches the trust-tier.
Google has moved away from
perimeter-based security
and IP-based trust.
What this gives
you is an employee
that could connect to the
internet from anywhere
in the world without a
VPN and be able to access
his or her applications.
There are three primary
Beyond Core principles.
The first one, connecting
from a particular network,
must not determine which
services you can access.
The second is access to services
is granted based on what we
know about you and your device.
And the third, all access to
services must be authenticated,
authorized, and encrypted.
To provide a simplified
example, consider the use case
of various employees at Google.
An employee may only
require a low tier of access
to retrieve access, for
example, to the cafeteria menu.
They don't need access to
more sensitive services,
like the HR portal.
Assigning the lowest
tier of access
required to complete a request
has several advantages.
It decreases the maintenance
of cost associated
with highly secure
devices and also improves
the usability of the device.
As a device is allowed to
access more sensitive data,
we require more frequent tests
of user presence on the device.
So the more we trust
a given device,
the shorter-lived
its credentials.
So to wrap this up, there
are three major takeaways.
Endpoints are critical
to cloud security.
More devices and applications
are being used by employees
from more locations
than ever before,
driving malicious actors with
more sophisticated hacks.
This creates a new
security paradigm
for businesses,
who ultimately need
the right strategy and tools
to keep their business safe.
Security at the browser, device,
and OS level is essential.
Chrome Enterprise provides
a secure entry point
to the cloud with Chrome OS
and the Enterprise features
and tools you need
to ensure employees
are compliant with the
Chrome Enterprise license.
And finally, trust
endpoints and apps
enable a tiered access strategy.
At Google, we focus on
a tiered access strategy
for users, applications,
and devices
to ensure data is secured
and always secure.
If you'd like to learn more
about Chrome Enterprise
Solutions for Chrome OS, you
can go to enterprise.googl
e.com/chrome/contact, and a
representative will be in touch
with you shortly.
If you like to learn more about
Chrome Enterprise Solutions
for Chrome browser, you can
go to chrome.com/enterprise.
We'll stay online for
a few more minutes
to continue to answer
questions as they come in.
Thank you very
much, and I hope you
found that this information
was very helpful.
Welcome, everybody,
back to the live Q&A.
So we've got a
couple of questions
here from the audience.
So let's run through some of
these questions right now.
First question
that's live is how
come there are five EMMs
that were chosen to integrate
with Chrome Enterprise?
So I highlighted in the
earlier presentation
that there are five current EMMs
that have been enabled and also
partnered with to basically
integrate and manage Chrome OS
devices currently.
We're not limited to these five.
There will be
additional partnerships
as a result of this.
But these were the first
five partners that actually
engaged with us to go live.
So we expect actually
more partnerships
to formulate as
a result of this.
Second question is, do I need
a Chrome Enterprise license
to use Chromebooks within my
Microsoft Active Directory
deployment?
So the answer to
that is yes, you do.
You will need to actually.
First off, you can actually
sign up for a trial.
And then secondly, if
you wish to proceed,
you can actually get an actual
Chrome Enterprise license,
and it would actually be an
annual subscription license.
The MSRP and the
associated costs with that
is below $50 a year,
and that actually
supports the Microsoft
Active Directory integration
with Chrome OS devices.
Let's see so we have some
other additional questions.
How much does the Chrome
Enterprise license cost?
That's a really good question.
So the typical cost for
Chrome Enterprise licensing,
again, is $50 a year.
It's a subscription-based
annual offering.
And also, let's see,
there's one more question
that's coming up live here.
Is Chrome OS Enterprise part
of Google Cloud or separate
to the Google division?
So Chrome Enterprise actually
sits underneath the Google
Cloud umbrella.
So Chrome Enterprise is actually
part of the Google Cloud
organization and team.
So with that, thanks
so much for watching.
Please tune in on Tuesday, June
5 for the next Cloud On Air.